februari 10th we will finally get to
play evolved from turtle rock studios
and those of you who were playing the
beta and for the past week or so have
been chatting about whether or not that
game lives up to its hype or whether
it'll be something you're interested in
playing just in a couple of weeks time
at Chris waters Eric Tay you guys been
playing it in the alphas and we've had a
sort of exclusive access to it as well
over the past you know year or so just
various stage of its development yeah so
I want to chew it out with you guys
there in a couple of weeks we obviously
have a review up on gamespot eventually
but from your sort of exposure to the
game over the past year especially
relation to the latest beta and Chris
first of all you what do you think about
evolved super into it yeah yeah i've
been i've been enjoying this game since
i first got to play and got the malish
by monster then demolished someone as a
monster it's really stressful but really
satisfying so like rip through some
people I think the concept is really
intriguing and you know in the limited
spurts that I've been able to play it
it's made good on it you know it's that
it is this unique kind of team dynamic
boss fight thing that has you know
whether you're playing as a human or
monster it's a substantially different
experience I like it have you had much
experience with playing with random
people against playing with like folks
you know we've had a couple of like in
office kind of game play tourneys alone
yeah so we like have a couple set ups
here so we try to play together when we
can cuz better play with people that you
know and then like roll the dice but I
did play with some matchmake with some
random folks during the beta this
weekend and I did with the Alpha
previously and I mean we've definitely
had some doozies like Tay and I were in
this one match with this medic who was
just like I have a sniper rifle awesome
monster head shots all day I was
seriously standing there like I was on
voice chat I was pinging him i was like
using my abilities to try to get him to
heal anybody and all we were all running
around with like one-third health for
like seventy percent of the match it was
a debacle but then you had that's like
one extreme then you can also get into
matches where it's like it's just
someone like teh on the other and i got
a general idea how the game flows like
knows what most played with his
strengths knows how to communicate even
without speaking on a headset you can
likely
your little way points to say stuff and
so you know it's like any cooperative
multiplayer game it kind of has that
little live or die depending on your
teammates yeah so yeah it's kind of the
nature of the game Eric you've been your
know sort of stranger to cooperative
online shooter he's been playing a hell
of a bunch of destiny since that came
out last year and what are your feelings
would uninvolved I think you're a little
bit more tempered than Chris's so for me
I see the fun factor in it I see that
when we play in the office when we're
landing together and there's generally
either all of us are hunters or all of
us are hunters and there's a monster
it's kind of more fun because I can talk
trash as the monster or I can talk trash
to the person that is the monster but
then you get those games where you do
get that one medic and we're basically
screwed right like you know you're
screwed because of this one player and
that's kind of frustrating because it's
almost like I was telling him earlier
I'd rather have a bot because this guy
is not doing his job in the bot well at
least he'll us we were we ran across the
map everyone's super low and we're
yelling at each other like this guy's
not really i'm about to die like I can't
we can't do anything we can't even
follow the monster right now hell we
can't even traverse because we might
gets picked off by random by wawa by the
stuff you can normally just shake off
and a medic tops you okay that could
that like we got killed by that stuff is
so is that sort of stuff like just the
norm would especially in a beta when
like people aren't really new to the
experience and they might not know
exactly what to do you think this is
like like you know Gears of War week one
call of duty week one just normal you
know par for the course I mean idiots
the thing though is that what call of
duty or like yours a war you have a
general idea of like we're gonna go do
this right but in evolved their defined
roles right there's a trapper there's a
assault there's a medic there's a
support each plays a very specific and
defined role that's important right like
you have to do your job or your team's
gonna suffer for especially the monster
knows what he's doing granted involved
does do a good job in showcasing you and
kind of giving a mini tutorial you know
before you play your character here's
your character here's kind of what
here's the different abilities
and and different guns that you have mmm
it does that but the thing is the person
the player has to utilize those things
if they don't utilize those things then
you kind of dead weight again I hate to
use the medic I again was like I have a
sniper rifle so he thinks like oh I'm
sources snipe the monster all the time
and he's not supposed to do that right
so my big thing is that it might
potentially be frustrating in the
beginning yeah part of part of like the
learning experience are playing with
randoms and I think it'll eventually get
better because like if it has a leveling
up system right so the higher you level
the higher like level people you'll
probably play with the I'm sure there's
an MMR so at that point the dedicated
people will be like in a level 10 15 and
then you know when you're playing with
those people they have to have a general
idea because they've they've invested
time but if you go in week one and you
have multiple bad experiences
potentially that can really make you not
want to play the game like so many
people don't have that much time anymore
to play games you know if you if you say
I'm gonna sit down and play to evolve
matches but you get to really bad ones
just by chance right yeah it's a look
look at the jaw totally as you can you
could as Chris said you could also have
a really great team and you can do what
you need to do its bit of a crapshoot
but it's a bit of crashing so like if
you play two bad games that gives you
this perception like oh man like I'm
just not gonna get anywhere and these
people don't know what they're doing and
maybe it's not even that clear to you
maybe it's just what the hell how do we
even have a chance against this monster
and we're getting destroyed you don't
necessarily realize that everyone's not
playing to their role and so your team
is not like at full strength you monster
tears you up that gives you the
impression that the game is imbalanced
and I think balance is so crucial to the
success of this game between the
different monsters between the different
hunters because even when we've been
playing like it at events and stuff with
people who have played before when we're
trying out new hunters and new monsters
like it there have been matches that
I've been like how did what could we
even have done differently really yeah
what does the opposite ever happen
because one of the things I worry about
this and like it's easy as comparison
something like your left for dead so
number one you don't really have your
classes some people you know stay at
front and some people kind of hold back
on or maybe our need a bit more medic
medics medicine or whatever like
first-aid rather every once in a while
but
they're not like defined roles but the
one thing in left 4 dead is that the AI
director this is literally like a system
that Valve how to make to make sure that
it did not get imbalanced whereas the
big antagonist in a game of evolved is a
person and that person might be really
good or that person might suck ass so
what happens like how often does that
ever happen where you're just in a game
and it's a complete blowout because the
individual doesn't have a clue what to
do happen during our live stream yeah
last week we we were four hunters we
know the game and then like the monster
came in and was just like kind of knew
the mechanics you could see them doing
monster stuff but just like the strategy
of like what you need to run you need to
like not you need to know when to be
engaged or not like we were just sitting
there wailing on and were like oh this
guy doesn't this person doesn't really
know what to do now we've got them we've
got them locked sewn up you know so but
you can also play against an AI monster
like you can choose as a team of four to
go in and play co-op or PvP you can play
all this stuff solo but yeah I mean to
your point about the AI director it's
kind of like in left 4 dead even though
the area director was there to give you
some kind of scaling like there's a
bottom there's like a minimum level you
have to be skilled at oral you're gonna
fail like you're just gonna fail and so
there it does have to be that time when
ya your enemy has to have a basic level
of competency for to be successful but
you also don't want them to be like
super ace it sounds like a lot of these
and worries will probably won't be known
until the game is out and it's actually
in sort of the wider and publix hands
and to that point there are multiple
ways in which you can purchase evolve
and this I don't know about this but
this seems completely insane to me some
of the like levels of DLC that are
happening so the video game evolved yeah
which is 12 unique maps 12 hunters and 3
monsters it's fifty to sixty dollars
yeah alright pick up back it there you
go it's a video game $60 got it the
whole box of video game there is a
season pass that's normal as well sure
you got three new monster skins they're
not new monsters right no skins yes and
make them look different yes slightly
different you also delay have glowy bits
magma magma Goliath magma crackin
and magma right those are the skins
great yeah for new hunters these are
also skins no those are controls our new
character hunters so you get one for
each class okay you combine up separate
if you want for seven dollars and 49
seconds yeah but what's this separate
I'm the buying separately is like cuz
then there you also there's also the
monster right which you can buy
separately for 15 bucks yes which yeah
doesn't I mean that makes the season
pass a look a lot more appealing how
much does a season-best the season
passes 2499 if you want though you can
buy the digital deluxe edition which has
both the season pass on the game just in
there together okay Sony's 80 bucks you
save a couple save save five bucks say
five bucks ah five bucks yeah unless
you're buying individual hunters then
you're saving more yes then that then as
you alluded to earlier there is a
separate monster in the monster
expansion pack which is only available
if you pre-order the game in which gives
you the savage goliath skin and the
behemoth when it becomes available but
you can buy the behemoth separately for
fifteen dollars if you want okay you can
still play against the behemoth right
yes so with the hunters and the monster
buying them is just to make them
playable for you got it you can still be
matched against the new monster you can
still be mad teamed up with the other
hunters uh yeah okay but and all the
mats are gone but so what here's the
question right is so like one of the big
things is like is not owning the monster
or not owning those extra hunters are
those hunters better is that monster but
you know i mean it comes down to that
and it's paid lion yeah and it's a lot
of that I hate like I hate mobis I hate
MOBAs just for this yeah the whole
concept of song an individual character
yeah or skins is a MOBA concept hmm and
I don't know if it's gonna work in this
setting do you like I'm like sure but
like the characteristics right it
doesn't affect it doesn't affect actual
gameplay right right looks the one thing
I do like is that they're not going down
the route of say like most first person
online games where you're basically
locked at like you can't play against
the goliaths also all the maps are going
to be available to everyone at all times
yeah which is there will be more maps to
come but and that won't segment the
playerbase yes that's why which is a
problem in almost every multiplayer
shooter six months down the line yeah is
that it cuts off the sort of the
high-end players with people who are
just sort of
like Fairweather playing every now and
again by the way there's more versions
of this game you can play potato by
there is the evolved monster race
edition e monster race pc monster got
done it which comes at evolve the
hunters hunting season pass which
includes the three months against for
new hunters and the behemoth want to if
you'd buy two additional hunters a fifth
unannounced could be anything could be
space monster could be Godzilla could be
go life is already Godzilla collide
Scott I could what it could be pretty
Godzilla dude could come on could be
like a spider demon yeah I want on a
rack knit monster could be Vince McMahon
could be Vince McMahon could be Bill
Clinton the NBA jam you know he was so
good in em dat nose and arielle phonetic
be free hunter knows this there's not
much in the Giant Bomb Marie Antoinette
hey Jess you gotta kill an ad for
monster skins that will be timed
exclusive for 30 days so it's just like
so what's the issue then is it is it the
is it the adding of more content is that
the pricing of that content or is it the
sheer articulation of different gets a
packet because when you get down to it I
don't think they're actually doing that
much wrong I like I hate DLC being
pushed before the games out because it
all makes already makes me feel that
when I spent sixty dollars you're
getting this truncated version of the
game yeah like just okay I get it an
ants the season pass let me know that
there will be stuff coming but don't
don't lay it all out letters always
don't numerate away you want to buy
seven dollars 49 cents like 1 X 2 deal I
I come on so it's a messaging thing it's
a packaging thing like what is the best
way to cuz is there a way you can
imagine like all right I want to order
evolve instead of going to like gamestop
I go to evolve calm or whatever the site
is and I click to buy it like Oh would
you like to add this show a little video
about what you can get for another few
bucks would you like to add this like is
it the consumer experience because like
I think that is entirely mental thing
because it's a whole mental game trying
to drive pre-orders because
pre-orders are still so huge as metris
metrics of success for companies as
insurers of game 6 success you know it's
a certain degree so they're trying to
play that mind game and get you to think
wow it's really an incentive for me to
buy this early but that's a double-edged
sword as you pointed out totally like
that doesn't seem to be anything they're
necessarily doing wrong but like you
were saying about the skins being like a
big turnoff for you and like for me just
knowing that there's all this game that
I'm not going to get unless I spend you
know what much is that monster race
edition I mean for me or something Aaron
1900 it's not even the skins because
like we said it's cosmetic if somebody
wants a magma Goliath great good for
that person it's it's just hopefully
like I said balance cuz even you you
hearkened it earlier like if I don't
have that fourth monster or that extra
hunter and that hunter is better for
some reason oh it's gonna be like to
mention why yeah I'm gonna have to buy
that character I also think though in
terms of the purchasing I really hope
that like they have something built into
the game like you I wise cuz a lot of
them strike mobis I mean they click the
shop and it shows you what it is and you
can buy it if you want you and then I'll
show you what it does or whatever I'm
like deeper than just store on the main
menu yeah right so you're currently it's
all there they're on for instance on
Steam and when you can't pre you can do
the pre-order on xbox one playstation 4
I don't know it's just gotten so
confusing to purchase games and 2015
Danny does not have that much like
attention span anymore and I don't know
there's something about it i think
involves going to be an interesting one
to see once it hits because both in
terms of the preview coverage they like
doled out pretty significant chunks over
a fairly long period of time yeah and
also it you know in this their their
messaging in terms of all the different
iterations of dlc like that stuff that
we can sort of we can see problems in
and feel like I'm uneasy about or you
know wonder about but what is it the
game then like if the game does super
well and everyone's like having a great
time playing it does that make all that
stuff okay or does it mean make it stuff
not matter as much like I think looking
back it's going to be interesting to see
how it kind of in retrospect you know
three months from now how we feel about
all this yeah the court of video game
public opinion is a
very strange place and there were all
horrible harvest parts of it and if
you'd like to leave your horrible
horrible part of it in the comments
section below please by all means do or
you going to pick up evolve which
version are you going to pick up which
skins do you want which do you want a
magma version of the lobby which you'd
be able to pay an extra five dollars for
please step on crack in yes please
steampunk Chris waters please let us
know I've half pay for that